you salut c'est cyrus en direct du
canada
voilà donc changement de décor du coup
les épisodes auront peut-être plus de
profondeur
il ya quelques semaines je vous ai
proposé de me poser des questions
philosophiques est maintenant temps d'y
répondre
c'est les questions et l'os
pour une question de clara pourquoi vous
avez quatre heures plus sérieusement le
djoker a tué des centaines de personnes
rendues batgirl tétraplégique
tu es un des robin et batman continue de
mettre à l'asile dont il va s'échapper
sans le tuer ou même simplement lui
briser la colone gentil classes dont
peut-on réellement parler de justice
quand on laisse aux mâles l'opportunité
de sévir à nouveau
autrement dit batman est il un vrai
gentil alors déjà pour moi batman c'est
un vrai gentil parce qu'il a une volonté
de faire le bien il a des valeurs
morales ancêtres garder en tête que le
joker il est malade mental donc il n'est
pas complètement conscient il est même
pas conscients du tout je pense de ce
qu'il fait ok du coup il est pas
forcément responsable maintenant s'il
avait été pleinement responsable la
question qui se cache derrière ta
question
c'est la question de la peine de mort
est ce que quelqu'un qui fait les
atrocités du joker mérite style d'être
tué par la société qui sont de julie
autre question quand une personne née
sourde
en quelle langue sont ses pensées en
fait une personne qui n'est sourde et
qui parlent la langue des signes
elle va pas penser comme nous de manière
auditive un peu toi on entend des voix
de tête etc
elle avait pensé visuellement et elle a
pensé en langue des signes
c'est donc une pensée visuel et même
dans leurs rêves et rêve en langue des
signes
jean par exemple si de la manière où
nous on peut parler dans le tenait que
tu peux les voir faire des signes
pendant qu'ils dorment du courant
atteindre des capacités cognitives les
sources sont bien au dessus de ce qui ne
le sont pas par exemple pour percevoir
un trou d'une partie d organiser ou
perçoit 1 organisation spatiale et ses
petites précisions sur la langue des
signes c'est pas une langue qui a été
inventée ex nihilo donc c'est à dire à
partir de rien comme l'espéranto ou le
morse danse est une langue qui est
indépendante naturelles culturelles et
genre par exemple il ya des dialectes de
langue des signes tu vois genre la
langue des signes américaine avec des
signes française c'est des langues des
signes différentes et compagnie
d'ailleurs julie si tu veux en savoir
plus sur le sujet je te propose le livre
de hellen keller qui s'appelle sourde
muette aveugle histoire de ma vie
voilà je pense que le titre est assez
explicite et à mon avis elle doit
forcément parler de ça enfin parler c
un csc tu m'as compris quoi si tu le lis
n'hésite pas à faire un retour et je ne
posterai sur la page facebook
histoire que ça serve à tout le monde ce
que ça peut aussi ça le but du coup de
fil
j'avais une autre question donc de
corentin liée à la précédente dans une
certaine mesure à quel point les gens
sont ils égaux les uns des autres
ok les hommes ils sont égaux dans la
nature d'accord genre tu as des grands
des petits des roues
voilà ta différents types des handicapés
gens qui naissent en bras les hommes
sont par contre égaux en droits c'est le
droit qui va rassembler chaque individu
en les considérant à égalité par exemple
la loi est la même pour tous peu importe
la provenance sociale ou ethnique pour
un même job on va avoir le même salaire
pour un même crime
on va avoir les mêmes peines extra extra
tout la déclaration universelle des
droits de l'homme
tous les hommes naissent libres et égaux
en droits voilà alors ça c'est la
théorie mais c'est pas toujours
malheureusement le cas donc c'est pour
ça que les y aider un truc pour lequel
il faut se battre continuellement toi
sauf si tu penses comme nietzsche que
c'est la nature qui doit régner et non
le droit pourquoi n'ai je pense à parce
que pour lui en fait le droit va
favoriser les plus faibles qui sont
normalement dominé par les plus forts et
donc ça va rabaisser les plus forts
question d'ismaël tu crois à la
perfection
question de manal peut-on vivre sans la
notion du temps et non manal on ne peut
pas parce que regardent en tant qu'être
vivant tu n'es ok donc c'est un bon
début et humeur sa fin donc c'est à
cette idée de début et de fin qui
implique forcément du temps c'est une
notion qui est en toi tu vois c'est
quelque chose qui est en nous on ne peut
pas vivre sans
d'accord ou alors tu peux mais tu es tu
n'es pas né comme le poisson et tu ne
vas pas mourir
et dans ce cas là tu m'appelles et je
vais présenter des gens très gentils
d'accord harry la musique est elle
indispensable à la vie après un petit
raisonnement par l'absurde
supposons la musique indispensable à la
vie est sourd entend pas la musique
ok donc le sourd pourrais pas vivre
or on sait que les sourds vivent ils
vivent d'ailleurs bien ils sont contents
et tout donc musique n'est pas
indispensable à la vie la réponse est
non
maintenant il ya une question qu'ont su
que tom tom c'est mon pote qui fait
freud qui a fait preuve d'un froid déjà
mis et qui m'aide pour les pierres du
coup de filet tout que je salue au
passage cette question qui va poser
c'est ok si tu devais choisir entre ne
pas faire l'amour
ok jusqu'à la fin de ta vie mais lui
fait pas l'amour talloires te masturber
ou n'écoutent pas de musique je peux pas
écouter une musique même dans la rue et
où il ya quelques jeux la musique tu
l'entends pas ok mais tu as loi de faire
ta propre musique et aurait écouté
qu'est-ce que tu choisis et tous les
deux maintenant sans hésitation on prend
on préfère ne pas faire l'amour et se
masturber et pour écouter la musique
donc ce que je veux dire par là ce que
non c'est pas indispensable [ __ ]
qu'est ce que c'est bon quoi tiens ça
m'intéressait savoir dans les
commentaires ce que vous pensez de ce
dilemme maintien et notamment s'il ya
des gens qui préfèrent faire l'amour
qu'ils expliquent pourquoi et tous et je
suis très conscient que c'est une
question bizarre en jeu
cette question devrait me tu as déjà
pense être le seul à exister sur terre
et que tout le reste ne serait qu'une
mise en scène est orchestrée par une
force un peu comme le truman show mais
il réellement aucun être vivant sur
terre juste toi n'ont jamais question de
franck comment l'évolution de la science
fait elle évoluer la philosophie alors
il ya deux choses
déjà il ya les questions éthiques qui
vont être liée aux progrès pas par
exemple les questions sur les clonages
oms ne poserait pas si on est parent
décollage tout simplement et ensuite il
y a les gros changement de perception
par exemple quand on a compris que tout
ne tournait pas autour de la terre mais
que la terre tournait autour du soleil
par exemple
bah ça ça décentralise l'homme si on
n'est plus au centre de l'univers
donc ça change pas mal de choses sur la
réflexion que l'on peut se faire sur
nous mêmes ou alors quand on a compris
que l'homme ne descend pas du singe tu
vois ce genre de chose la question de
victor l'homme peut-il et doit-il manger
les animaux non mais qu un lien les
animaux tu vois on le veut on les
respecte on va pas non plus les manger
quoi ça serait vraiment pas de sens quoi
plus une question de respect quoi ça se
peut pas kiss you d'adrien penses tu que
notre pensée est uniquement formatés par
les éléments extérieurs et donc par
principe de causalité déterminisme tout
ça tout ça
cette question va pas marrer avec celle
de tom aujourd'hui on sait que notre
pensée est un ensemble de réactions
chimiques qui se fait dans nos neurones
alors comme toutes ces questions sont
régies par les lois de la physique
possède ton un libre arbitre question
très intéressante
alors pourquoi il n'y aurait pas de
libre arbitre à prendre une heure
logiquement c'est simple une pensée
c'est un signal électrique dans notre
cerveau et donc les signaux électriques
arrivent avant qu'on fasse notre choix
en gros pour que le libre arbitre
existe il faudrait que une pensée cause
son existence à moi même qu'elle
n'existe ce qui est impossible puisque
une pensée ne peut pas être sa propre
origine ok je vous la fais simple mais
j'ai trouvé un article super intéressant
je suis mis dans la description et qui
en anglais donc c'est assez hardcore au
niveau du langage
donc je sais tu expliquer ça est un
professeur d'université qui s'appelle
peter c est qui a trouvé une alternative
à ça cette quiche par peter henrot
l'information n'est pas uniquement faite
grâce aux signaux électriques qui sont
savoir un instant présent mais elle est
aussi la grâce aux connexions qu'il y as
entre les neurones et c'est ce qu'on
appelle les synapses et les neurones
peuvent modifier les synapses des autres
neurones pour leur donner plus ou moins
d'importance plus ou moins de poids si
tu veux et du coup ces neurones modifié
vont émettre et recevoir des
informations de manière différente que
ce qu'ils ont toujours fait comme le
libre arbitre ne peut pas se faire sur
les signaux électriques qui circulent
dans un instant présent comme on l'a vu
parce que la pensée ne peut pas se créer
tout seul on va se concentrer sur ses
synapses hockey et sur ces chemins et
donc sur la possibilité de signaux futur
on va prendre l'exemple d'un train qui
parle de new york par les variations du
go donc d'un bout à l'autre des états
unis pour que ce sera arrive à san diego
il faut que l'aiguillage des voies
ferrées soit de sorte que le train soit
sur la bonne voie et 7 aiguillages de
voix il se fait avant que le train passe
d'accord prenons un exemple concret de
l'achat d'une voiture en quelques
entache est une voiture donc on a tous
des critères kilométrage
couleurs marques d'accor quand tu vois
une voiture qui correspond à ses
critères là tu dis ok bon sens et elle a
donc c'est pas le choix qu'ont fait
consciemment ce qu'on fait consciemment
c'est les critères de ce futur choix
porté le cerveau peut créer des critères
pour une future activité mentale ce qui
peut prendre du temps pour que le chemin
soit optimale et que le système soit
prêt lorsque la bonne voiture passera en
fait il rajoute que notre capacité à
exercer du libre arbitre ne vient pas
forcément de notre sentiment d'être à la
source de quelque chose mais que le plus
important c'est notre capacité à jongler
entre des options et donc à garder des
possibilités de choix pour être mangés
l'adversité d'où ils tombent effet
question de célia pourquoi les gens
s'attachent style autant à la religion
quand il ya des preuves scientifiques
qui contredisent les livres religieux et
d'éminents scientifiques qui sont super
religieux j'avais commencé à lire un
livre des bogdanoff à ce sujet que
c'était le visage de dieu je crois et je
les prenais plein d'exemples pseudo
scientifiques qui croyaient en dieu
george est pas moi par exemple newton
einstein
je t'ai mis une vidéo aussi dans la
description où il en parle un petit peu
après quand on dit quoi en dieu c'est
pas forcément effectivement le dieu
personnel bibliques comme on peut
l'imaginer il ya beaucoup de choses qui
rentrent dans ce concept de dieu en plus
je peux très bien croire en dieu sans
croire tout ce qu'il ya dans les livres
religieux et je vais te donner une
petite citation de pascal que tu dois
sûrement connaître qui est le coeur a
ses raisons que la raison ignore
mais en fait c'est pas du tout une
citation d'amour donc de loeb et tous
genres les meufs qui se prennent en
photo en noir et blanc le cas ces
raisons qu'il a raison il ya un [ __ ]
trop pas du tout pas du tout c'est pas
du tout ça en fait le coeur ce que c'est
la foi c'est dans le sens de ce que
parce qu'elle veut dire ce que la foi et
la raison sont deux choses différentes
la croyance ta foi tu la soumet pas à ta
raison monsieur la question de le
philosophe donc du philosophe je sais
pas que dirais tu aux personnes pour qui
la philosophie à une image repoussante
et regarde je leur dirai regarder
l'épisode du coup de fil mon vieux petit
mot sur le philosophe le philosophe je
vois c'est ce que je vous conseille
d'aller voir c'est un singe un mec comme
moi qui dois avoir mon âge qui a fait un
qui a un bloc de philo qui est étudiant
en philo qui en plus d'être très cool et
très pertinent ça c'est assez sympa gens
sont derrière article c'est sûr homo
comics us donc il parle pas mal du rire
extra donc tu vas beaucoup plus en
profondeur beaucoup plus référencés et
sai mouk à les y jeter un coup d'oeil si
la philosophie vous intéresse question
de danic et légumes à quoi sert la philo
c'est toutes les réponses alors pour
ceux qui connaissent pas dans les
cailloux là c'est un youtuber qui fait
des vidéos de philosophie aussi mais pas
que la philo c'est aussi de la
sociologie lui va prendre un sujet comme
là où le jeu vidéo et il va en parler
pendant un petit quart d'heure
il va faire que sa vidéo là dessus c'est
très intéressant
je vous ai mis le lien de sa chaîne dans
la description
donc allez-y allez jeter un coup d'oeil
et si si vous êtes intéressé par la
philosophie et que vous le connaissez
pas forcément ça vous intéresse
voilà c'est tout pour les questions on
se revoit une prochaine fois pour un
vrai épisode du coup de fil cette fois
voilà en tout cas j'espère que j'espère
que tout va bien merci encore pour vos
encouragements genre c'est vraiment
vraiment très cool ça me fait ça me fait
toujours autant plaisir toujours ça me
fait ça me faisait pas plus plaisir
avant tu vois pareil je rends pas
regardé par la fenêtre parce que c'est
un peu l'apocalypse ici allez font
montre on est fous on est fous là allez
quoi est-ce qu'on n'a rien à voir voilà
voyez vous pas je veux terminer cette
série de réponses par une petite blague
ces deux bonbons qui marchent dans la
rue et là il ya un flic qui arrivent et
qui fait aux veaux papiers s'il vous
plaît voilà voilà donc du love et les
pis voilà chao et 1 3 pour 1 prochaine
peut être utile